tu sais
pour cela
mais modère tout le public de se lever à
on va décrire une personne grâce à des
questions que vous allez me poser au
liberia alors attention valérie parce
que kelly n'a elle devait être là donc
après si j'ai une question libanaise y
est ce que c'est une femme
oui c'est une femme est une femme donc
tous les hommes ce seuil est cassé et un
gros rat but de pujol ya un petit temps
de réaction est allé après sa mort et
vous savez je voulais poser comme
question est ce qu'il ya fait ce qui
porte la moustache
donc oui je sais ce qui est comme vous
une porte c'est merci est ce que comme
ben oui port de la moustache
non non non mais maintenant oui c'est
qu' après gille est ce que ces personnes
à des lunettes
ce que cette personne a dû est non
seulement voilà toutes les personnes qui
n'ont pas de lunettes à ma mère dont qui
ont scandé lunettes sur rhodia pas de
lunettes allez gilles c'est bon mathieu
est ce que cette personne abonnée
supérieure à ces 1,7 à ta question
abruti
je dois dire est ce que la personne a la
chance pour que d'avoir les cheveux
blonds c'est ce que je disais pas pardon
je me pose une question est ce que la
personne est blonde
oui je dis oui donc toutes les brunes ça
se réduit la maxime est ce que cette
femme un tatouage
oui toutes les personnes qui n'ont pas
de tatouage peuvent s'asseoir reste la
croix le reste dans sa version
personnelle reste il ne reste pas sur
youtube line up éclair à à les rejoindre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors parlez bien dans le micro comment
ça va clair merci d'être avec nous
claire tu très content de vous voir mais
ça va ma clé rooney tu te fais un gros
bisou bien merci
qu'est-ce que tu prennes ton micro
t'inquiète pas qu'est ce que tu fais
dans la vie je suis maman au foyer le
combien d'enfants 5 5 enfants garçons
copine mes copines 80 jeunes qu'à 30 ans
aujourd'hui bon anniversaire aura
peut-être un cadeau pour une personne du
public dans un instant magnifique cadeau
c'est une maman de cinq enfants et on
envoyait une vidéo vous allez me dire si
vous reconnaissez des gens web une vidéo
tous les soirs
[Musique]
pourquoi notre mère je souhaite qu'elle
soit gâtés car elles ont fait beaucoup
pour nous toute l'année l'effort avec
cinq magnifiques enfants est le plus
beau cadeau qu'on pourrait avoir
franchement c
gâtés que chaleureuse
elle profite un petit peu pour elle je
t'aime mon coeur je t'aime
14 n'est pas du tout du tout jamais que
c'est un public où j'ai mon cadeau de
vous à nous avons fait ben moi nous
c'est un cadeau voilà pour nous s'il se
voit jamais une femme n'a autant pleuré
devant moi par contre me paraît que tu
as jamais pris craint pas pour venir
jusque paris n'ont jamais alors je vais
te montrer il ya trois cartes qui vont
apparaître à l'économie trois cartes et
tu vas devoir en choisir une
en gagner un cadeau bien près de moi que
tu veux prendre celle de droite haut bas
les français de droite je sais pas ce
qu'il y'a jetons pas la pierre je te lis
choisir allez on va prendre celle de
droite regarde ce qui se cache un subtil
gagne ma chérie parce que je vais te
dire ça faire les enfants nous ont dit
on rêve c'était de faire un spa et bien
je t'offre un an de spa
aubin
les autres cadeaux on va voir ce qu'il y
avait derrière les autres cadeaux
regardez alors il y avait des cadeaux de
jouets pour les enfants et il y avait et
il y avait un séjour dans un parc
d'attractions tu gagnes le spa mais tu
gagnes bien sûr tu gagnes tout tu crois
[Applaudissements]
je ne pouvais
[Musique]
non
thomas reagan rendez vous tout au long
de l'année dans tous les spas
partenaires mais voilà vous allez kiffer
vous gagnez un séjour pour toute la
famille dans le meilleur parc
d'attractions de monde
europa park en hôtel 4 étoiles pour
découvrir les 100 attractions et le
spectacle et des jouets pour tous les
enfants
c'est pour nous à faire
il dit
[Applaudissements]